now you've been very generous giving
Tesla credit for the advances that
they've made in electric car technology
orko president Martin leach claims
you're ready to set the bar even higher
than what Tesla has done saying that
Tesla is 2.0 next TV is trying to be 3.0
what does that mean
so we could be I say that we are working
on car three auto and Clark you know if
you kind of look at the automotive
industry evolution I kind of think of it
in three phases right in the first
whatever 120 year old industry the first
phase was really about mechanical
systems and hydraulic systems in a
mechanical engineers run ran these
companies and that was really the skill
set a lot of the innovation happened in
the mechanical systems the second phase
called $2 was really the movement to
electronics and electrification and that
was the second phase of the innovation
you know Tesla obviously leading in that
in that shift the third phase is really
about digital systems and more
personalization more of the connected
vehicle how actually the car becomes a
robot in a computer and this is really
going to be about the software about
personalization about data and so that's
that's what we mean by Karthi out of how
many cars do you plan to make in terms
of volume we haven't disclosed that yet
that's why I add we'll all the
manufacturing be in China for the market
a market entries in China initially the
first few vehicles will be launched in
China and those vehicles will be
manufactured in China for the for us the
next TV us the US company our market
entry will be us and we are evaluating
manufacturing options right now
interesting because I know you're
working with J AC to build a car do you
ultimately aim to have your own
manufacturing it's an option you know we
prefer not to I think we know between
now and when we launch our manufacturing
I think manufacturing of vehicles will
also evolve I don't know if you saw the
news Volkswagen actually signed up with
JSC as well as a partner and so that's
good for us you know they're picking
them as a partner and we picked them as
a partner we don't want to commit too
soon to having our own manufacturing I
think for us the innovation is really
going to be in the design in the UI in
the software manufacturing is a core
competency the auto industry has
for many years it's hard to disrupt that
and so they're open to partnerships and
we'll explore all the different options
and I know you said that you want this
to be more affordable than a Tesla how
much more for any ask me that again it
will be more affordable I mean I
wouldn't say be more affordable because
we have better than Tesla I think it is
you know it's it's the truth is right in
any technology lifecycle evolution as
more people buy new technology the
volume drives costs down so the more
evey companies there are the more
companies that target autonomous driving
light are caustic own and come down
sansa costs are going to come down that
helps the whole industry so part of the
reason why I believe will be more
affordable by the time we'll be in the
market some of the high costs that we
face today will come down